if our personal trainer and I wanted to  get new clients and I had no money every  single person can do cold DMS to 100  people a day and get new business and  you will fail and you will over time get  better at it because you have to learn  what's the first message you want to  send I'll give you the easiest one hey  I'm doing this thing do you know anybody  who'd be interested in doing that thing  then you add some sort of offer and I'm  doing it for free and I guarantee this  you're giving the offer to somebody and  you're not soliciting them you're  soliciting a friend make a post see who  likes it of your friends and then  message their friends as well in a  three-way message because in that way it  gets out of the request box and gets  into the Inbox and they have to usually  respond because there is some social  capital there if you do 100 messages a  day you'll have more business than you  know to do with and not enough time to  do more of the DMS